hello
time to do your laundry huh
saturday night saturday is laundry night
i know
every saturday at 8 15
easy to anticipate
what are you implying i'm implying that
you're a creature of habit
and if something were to prevent you
from doing your laundry on saturday at 8
15
you might find it
unpleasant
knuckle under my ass
oh no
are all the machines taken
what are you gonna do
no problem
i'll just
do my laundry another night
another night well i guess you can try
but deep inside your heart you'll know
that laundry night is always saturday
night
woman you are playing with forces beyond
your ken
yeah well your ken can kiss my barbie
sheldon
sheldon
sheldon
yes
where are my clothes
your clothes yes i left them in the
washers and when i went down to get them
they were gone really
despite the sign that says do not leave
laundry unattended
sheldon where are my clothes you know i
do recall seeing some female
undergarments where was that oh yes
earlier this evening
i happened to gaze out the window and a
brazier caught my eye
do those look familiar
how the hell did you get them up on that
telephone wire
when you understand the laws of physics
penny anything is possible
and may i add more ha-ha
get them down apologize never well then
may i suggest you get a very long stick
and play panty pinata
wait sheldon this has gotten way out of
hand okay i've done some stupid things
you've done some stupid things haven't
we just call it even and move on with
our lives i've done no stupid things
look you've got to meet me halfway here
i am meeting you halfway i'm willing to
concede that you've done some stupid
things
hey you guys are talking again good
what happened
leonard remember when i said it was on
well now it's junior rodeo on
oh
not junior rodeo
what did you do
i had no choice leonard she ruined
laundry night
oh
[Music]
forever